- [Instructor] We're
told, in the beginning
of each episode of a certain game show,
each contestant picks a certain
door out of three doors.
Then the game show host randomly picks
one of the two prize bundles.
After each round, each
contestant receives a prize
based on the door they picked
and the bundle the host picked.
Matrix A represents the possible prizes
for the first round.
All right, so for example,
if the contestant picks door three
and the host picks bundle
one, the prize is $300,
but if the contestant picks door three
and the host picks bundle two,
the prize would be $0, all right.
And then they say matrix B
represents the possible prizes
for the second round.
All right, that's fair.
They also tell us the
second round can also
be a lightning round.
In this case, the prizes are doubled.
Matrix C represents the possible prizes
during a lightning round.
Complete matrix C.
So pause this video and see
if you can figure that out
and then we'll work through this together.
All right, so matrix C is a
scenario where we're dealing
with a lightning round,
and remember in a lightning
round, the prizes are doubled
but it's the second round.
It's doubled relative to
what it would have been
in the second round.
So what it would have been in
the second round is matrix B.
So another way to think about it is,
matrix C is going to be
equal to two times matrix B.
And we know when we multiply a matrix
times a scalar like this,
times just a number,
we just multiply each of
these entries by that number.
So let's do that.
If we take $600 and multiply that by two,
that is going to be $1,200.
And that makes sense.
We just said for each
corresponding scenario
the prizes are doubled
in a lightning round.
So if the contestant picks door one,
host picks bundle one, instead of $600
it's going to be $1,200.
Keep going, instead of
$200, it's going to be $400.
All I'm doing here is I'm
multiplying each of these entries
by two to get the corresponding
entry in matrix C.
Keep going, instead of $300 here,
multiply that by two,
you're going to get $600.
Instead of $300 here,
We're almost there.
Instead of $0 here,
well, zero times two is still $0.
And then last but not least,
instead of $400 right over here,
that times two is going to be $800.
Now there's one more question
that they have below the
screen right over here.
Let me scroll up a little bit.
So they tell us matrix
D is defined as follows:
D is equal to A plus B.
What does matrix D represent?
So pause the video and think
about that for a second.
Well, if we add two matrices,
we're going to add all
the corresponding entries.
And so what it tells you is
what is the combined prize
for both rounds one and two
based on what the contestant
picks and what the host picks.
So matrix D, that top
left entry will tell you,
okay, in total, if the
contestant picked door number one
and the host pick bundle
number one, what would you get?
Cause it would be $100 dollars plus $600.
So it would be total
for rounds one and two,
assuming we don't have the lightning round
like we had in matrix C.